so as you know lgbt people
are very oppressed so incredibly
oppressed
and persecuted in this country uh but at
the same time the lgbt acronym keeps
expanding because people are so
desperate to
to invent some new lgbt identities so
they could be a part of the club so they
could be
you know involved as well or to bolster
their resume within the club
they'll they'll make up new identities
to be a part of it
see i've never heard of an oppressed
group that functions exactly
like that like can you think of any
historical example of a of a group
that's persecuted and meanwhile people
who aren't in the persecuted group
are actually pretending to be in it just
to get themselves
a dose of that sweet persecution help
help i'm being repressed
i can't think of any example of that
historically i don't think so this is
unprecedented
um and the other possible explanation is
that lgbt people aren't persecuted at
all so i'll let you
determine what no anyway as part of this
expansion we now have something called
pansexuality and pansexuality is a
really uh sought-after identity these
days
it's one of the newest things hot off
the presses people are
are really into it celebrities are
coming out as pansexual
uh left and right everyone is pansexual
all of a sudden
so that raises a question which is what
the hell
is a pansexual what the hell
are you well a pansexual as far as i
understand it
is someone who's attracted to either sex
but isn't that the same as a bisexual
well you might think so
but apparently not they we're told these
are two different things
um how are they different what's the
distinction
well to answer that question i think we
have to go back to consult
the wise sages of a tick tock who are
experts on many things
but especially on all sexual matters
and we've got a few videos here kind of
explaining what pansexuality is and how
it's different from bisexuality and i
thought this was
just a good it's good learning
opportunity for all of us so let's uh
let's start
watching the videos bi versus pan in 30
seconds or less
bisexuality is the ability to feel
emotionally physically or even sexually
attracted to more than one gender
this can be two four six eight or even
all of them this can be with or without
a preference
pansexuality is the ability to feel
attraction regardless of someone's
gender or sex or gender expression
also explained as the ability to feel
attraction to all genders without a
preference
look i made you richard
what okay so so they're literally just
the same thing
did am i having a seizure or something
or didn't she just
repeat herself as exactly the same thing
sorry wait no no no
bi is the the ability to be attracted to
anyone of any gender
and pan is the ability to be attracted
to anyone
regardless of gender i think that's the
distinction she made
uh you see it you see the distinction me
neither i don't see it either
um because there isn't one you know it's
just two words for the same thing
and there's a lot of that in the lgbtq
xyz
acronym a lot of the same thing
repeating over and over again same for
the 192 genders
it's just sort of like the same thing
over and over again because in reality
there are only two
but um i don't know i maybe she did a
bad job of explaining it so let's uh
let's let's watch another one
pansexual is a bisexual same thing you
just gotta get over
these years of you know i gotta get over
my years of internalized biphobia
i was bi for literally three years until
i realized that i'm pam if you don't
know this video is directed at me
so hey bae thanks for the even more
clout than i already have also
the likes to comment ratio already
amazing let me explain
bisexuality and pansexuality to you
because you obviously need a lesson
bisexuality versus pansexuality for
dummies here we go bisexuality
oh i think that girl's attractive oh i
think that guy's attractive
oh i think that non-binary person is
attractive pain sexuality
oh i think that person is attractive oh
they're a girl okay
oh i think that person's attractive oh
they're non-binary okay
oh i think that person is attractive oh
they're a guy okay
do you get it bisexuality attraction to
more than one gender pansexuality
attraction to anyone regardless of
gender it's mainly
feelings based on personality based
thanks for the panphobia thank you
first of all what is it on tiktok with
the uh with the cackling they're always
doing
these girls on tick tock i don't make
any assumptions but
these girls on tick tocks they they're
always uh cackling
i'm not sure what that is exactly and
why do they always edit the videos so
that it cuts out the last word they said
before the
but anyway panphobia she says yes we
have panphobia now
there are people out there who have a
phobia of pansexuals apparently
i mean sure i run into this thing all
the time haven't we all seen
people running through the streets oh no
the pansexuals are coming
it's a pansexual second thought i
haven't run into that at all because um
nobody can have a phobia of pansexuals
because that's a made-up thing it's like
being afraid of a pansexual is like
being afraid of
peter pan it's it's an imaginary thing
but let's keep going here maybe we could
find a video that makes sense of all of
this
and um i'm already just looking at the
image here and i feel like
this is a person who can
illuminate and enlighten us all let's
watch guess what
my patience is run out pansexuality is
not inherently biphobic they are both
valid
sexualities both of them and while yes
i have seen pansexual people use that
label for questionable reasons
they pretty quickly get it once you
explain things to them
they do and not only that but do you
know who likes to use specific or micro
labels
neurodivergent people sometimes we just
have to do whatever we can to feel safe
and comfortable
and using a more specific label can be
our outlet for that
if you took all that energy you spend
calling people biphobic and saying
they're performing by erasure and just
educated them there would be less
biphobia
there would be less by erasure because
you've explained it
and people will know the difference i've
had it with you guys jesus
that was a uh safety pin
in his hers that individual's face
right that was a safety pin that's what
i thought anyway uh pansexuality is not
inherently biphobic
did you hear that pansexuality is not
inherently biphobic
and this settles the age-old debate i
think it was uh it was a fact aristotle
who was the first to postulate
that pansexuality is not inherently
biphobic so i'm glad that we've
established that he also says
that we need to or rather the individual
because i honestly
really have no idea but this person says
that we need to fight
by erasers i'm not sure what a buy
eraser is
it might be the kind that erases both
pencil and pen
i'm not sure somehow i'm just feeling
more confused the more that we watch
let's try one more to see if maybe this
will finally
make everything make sense for us what's
the difference between omnisexual and
pansexual
omnisexual people like all genders while
pansexual people like people based on
their personality
so yes they both like all genders but
gender is more relevant to omnisexual
people than pansexual people
most of the time pansexual people are
blind to gender while most of the time
omnisexual people are not blind to it
comment any genders or sexualities you
want me to explain and compare
life for per five so now we got
now we have omnisexual two so we got
bisexual pansexual omniscient
all to describe people who are attracted
to either
gender or regardless of gender or
inclusive of gender or in spite of
gender or whatever
this cannot possibly get more redundant
or arbitrary or absurd
i'm demisexual i only feel sexual
attraction when i form an emotional
connection
if there's no strong bond it's not an
option get to know me
i'm demisexual
[Music]
yeah you're a woman in other words so
you you want to have a strong bond with
someone
in order to be attracted to them so
that's just like every
woman that has ever existed you just
call yourself that that's fine too
um so okay you know i said i'm more
confused the more that we watch these
but i'm actually not i'm
that's i'm being facetious i know
exactly what's going on here it's not
confusing at all
people have defined their identity and
meaning and purpose and entire
personality and their existence by these
sexual labels
and this is what happens when you do
that i mean the ironic thing is that
you know they're trying to escape labels
escape what they call a rigid binary
and they can't escape it because the
binary is natural
it's it's biological but what they found
in their
in their their flight from labels is a
whole bunch of additional
labels so now they're more labeled than
they've ever been
and they're arguing with each other over
the finest little distinctions
and i guess they take comfort in that
because it is easier to
adopt a label than it is to develop a
personality
and find actual meaning in your life
also as we've seen in some of these
videos
having a label like this gives you an
excuse to dress like a character from a
tim burton movie there's white things in
the air
and that in the end i think is the real
point